harry and megan are greatly influenced
by princess diana
megan's emotional revelation that she
struggled with suicidal thoughts
mirrors what dai confessed to the world
25 years ago
i just didn't want to be alive anymore
and that was a very
clear and real and frightening
constant thought you'd wake up in the
morning
feeling you didn't want to get out of
bed you felt misunderstood
and just very very low in yourself
so that i've never felt this way before
and i need to go
somewhere and i was told that i couldn't
that it wouldn't be good for the
institution
in diana's famous 1995 interview on the
bbc's panorama
she says she battled postpartum
depression after the birth of prince
william
and just like megan the princess said
the royal family did nothing to help her
well it gave everybody
a wonderful new label his diana's
unstable and diana's um mentally
imbalanced
and unfortunately that seems to have
stuck on and off over the years
so were you thinking of harming yourself
were you having suicidal thoughts
yes this was very very clear
in diana's case she did harm herself the
princess battled bulimia she would also
cut herself yes i did inflict upon
myself
i didn't like myself i was ashamed
because i couldn't cope with the
precious what did you actually do
well i just hurt my arms and my legs i
am concerned for my mental welfare
well maybe i was the first person ever
to be in this family
whoever had a depression or was ever
openly tearful
one of the people that i reached out to
who's continued to be a friend and
confidant was
one of um my husband's mom's best
friends one of diana's best friends
because it's like who else could
understand
what's what's actually like on the
inside suffering and feeling trapped
megan revealed she surrendered a lot of
freedom when joining the firm when i
joined that family that was the last
time until we
came here that i saw my passport my
driver's license my keys
all that gets turned over